i saw this over the weekend uh
fauci is under fire for reportedly uh
experimenting on dogs
he's facing uh he's spent four hundred
thousand dollars on research infest
infecting dogs with parasites
but is that part of his is that what
they do first of all he didn't the nih
does he okayed it
yeah he has to go through him but isn't
that what they do oh god you [ __ ] with
dogs people dogs don't i've heard like
other what kind of dogs do we know
because there's certain dogs i'm okay
with it first of all i think
we have to we have to stop for a sec
guys so so the nih the national
institute of health
grants gives government grants to very
important research got it
fauci is a the head of nih i i j this is
going to come as a big surprise
everybody but he has a large staff a
large group of people that delineate
these different grants based on a whole
bunch of criteria okay
dogs suffer from from from parasites
sometimes to get the medicines that save
your dog's life and save your life they
do use animals in the last stage of
testing for medicines a lot of times are
have to be done on
animals because you are the next
case here this is political horse [ __ ]
it's just horse [ __ ]
it just is it's like i mean i'm not a
fan of jesus i'm not a fan of falci but
i want to be fair too yeah but it isn't
it isn't because his
his
his team did operate on on dogs
right yeah the way they also did on
monkeys and on chimps
with hiv a lot of that study on hiv that
gave birth to these produce inhibitors
and stuff
that [ __ ] was done on [ __ ] chimps
because they're very close and it's
terrible research it sucks yeah they're
back in the 80s when i was going to
college there was a huge to do about
what they were doing the monkeys at the
nih yeah man there's a lot of stuff and
some of it's not necessary some of it
might be but like you made to take one
study four so out of 20 billion dollars
i think is the grants they give 400 000
to some study somewhere about parasites
with dogs this is a this is fox news
horseshit yeah they're just trying to
throw something out there against
fountains yeah they hate you so much
yeah this is this is like i'm so done
with cnn and fox news i'm so done with
with these opinion makers that are doing
whatever they can to describe both sides
yeah
just kind of did your own did your
brother send you that article
oh no i just i actually just found it on
instagram and everything all right well
you're probably done with chrome event
i like read the whole entire thing but
like it's fox news yeah
you're not gonna like my next one yeah i
mean it fox and tucker crosstalk
though if it was from the hill or
somewhere like in the middle then we
could go with it but fox news says one
agenda to destroy anybody especially
balchi which i don't like vouching right
tucker carlson i wanted to be fair with
your criticism tucker carlson literally
said and then and
he went through the whole thing with
andrew cuomo and he said and he may be a
made member of the mafia
tucker carlson come on dude please like
i like what you say sometimes but when
you do that you just lose credibility
but we also don't need that like quote
we don't need it he's already fine we're
good we don't need to accuse them being
part of the mafia it's like i mean they
probably are but the thing is yeah is
you know the whole thing is like come on
dude
like some of this stuff between uh
that's where the media on both sides
right and left has lost my [ __ ] trust
well it's lost it's like the public's
trust correct so what do you what do you
watch i try to watch bbc i try to watch
i listen to npr it's tough to find
anything i have to say i have trouble i
take everything out so i don't watch it
either because of the you know same
reasons but it's just
like there's got to be something out
there at least that's like kind of look
there is in the middle or like give me
real facts yeah just remember that
journalists are under enormous pressure
to stay relevant and get clicks and as
long as that's the case journalists are
more interested in the story that sells
which means
the
whatever they who they destroy doesn't
matter it's it's being first and being
loudest it's not about being that's why
you see so much covet and delta yeah
because that's what people are going to
tune into of course
and and they make money not off telling
you the truth they make money off your
attention